The dark web, however, is not just an eBay for illegal purchases.
It's also used by radical extremists to communicate and spread propaganda,...
...but not all activity going on down in the dark web is illegal.
TOR, for instance, receives 60% of its backing...
...from the US State Department and the Department of Defense to act as a secure network...
...for both government agencies and political dissidents fighting oppressive regimes.
Over the past decade, the dark web has empowered activists...
...to spread news during the Arab Spring...
...and encourage whistle-blowers to release information.
The dark web as a tool to help journalists uncover the truth was made popular by Wikileaks.
Now, news organizations such as The New York Times and The Guardian...
...all host dark web drop sites for uploading anonymously-leaked tips and documents.
It's also helped domestic violence victims hide from online stalkers...
...and allowed ordinary citizens to surf the web...
...without being tracked by advertisers or even the government.